all right yep Ready
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them hey Tasties taste buddies
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds the hottest day on record
of the earth you know that's disgusting
outside what today's the hottest day of
on earth and the Earth's history of our
recorded Earth temperatures
temperature on the Earth oh my God yeah
in the history of of since we've been
taking note
this is gonna Universe really just
pushing that pressure down on us huh
yeah just isn't letting up it's hot it's
muggiest I thought this was gonna be a
travesty in here today it's not too bad
another smog another dirty air warning
in New York I was just some of this I
check air quality now on The Daily and I
never did before uh you need to be doing
this I've heard the theory twice
now that the air quality is the same as
it always has been it's just it's a
thing that they can
yeah that helps and just don't mind that
just Fat Joe it
uh we got a big day here today we're
doing purple monster versus purple
monster Grimace versus Barney why well
in honor of this dude I cannot begin to
tell you how many people have messaged
me
something they brought back or something
new
new brand new Hollow depresses the
Grimace Shake limited time only
people going cuckoo bananasaur like
lining up like the cronuts
oh so are they hard to get this is uh
McDonald's selling item everywhere they
have unhappy not hard to get but
everyone's making content about it and
going viral in the back of Grimace what
does it smell like what's the nose I
gotta tell you
a friend of mine said
friend of mine told me she said I had
she said I had you know what kind of
berry
my friend hold on hold on let me tell
you let me tell you my friend had it and
she said he's good today she said well
she goes she goes I had the grammar
Shake she goes it gave me a headache
from the brain freeze she goes but it
was delicious and she said it tasted
just like berries
crunch berries
yep that's it
smells exactly what grocery
I was going to say Fruity Pebbles but
it's crunch berries oh my God yeah you
know what I found out too that's bad
crunch berries the dye they use which is
in everything like Skittles and M M's
and everything in between uh is really
really bad for us in band in every other
country so now I'm like oh man maybe I
should eat crunch berries anymore not
that I have I've had them once and left
yeah I'm eating them once every three
years at this point yeah uh uh it's the
Grimace birthday meal
um how old do you guys think Grimace is
I already looked right now oh God yeah I
didn't mean to I didn't mean to it was
on the screen though all right mofo how
old do you think uh well is are they
dating him as like when they created him
at what age he was or since the day that
he was that we ever heard about him to
now how old is he
um I guess when the animator sold it to
McDonald's so like when they sold 2000
like this is Grimace he's a 30 year old
taste bud or not just like Grimace was
it was shown first in 1962 so today he's
60. this is the M1 McDonald's official
age that doesn't change like South Park
kids are the same age no no every year
we're supposed to celebrate him no no no
but he doesn't but does he get older
or her I guess yeah yeah yeah so then no
they are saying his name so so okay so
they said x amount of trips around the
Sun is what they okay so okay but I'm
just asking one question is it when they
were like hey everybody this is Grimace
did he have an age then or are we just
saying how how long has he been around
like
well it's a big deal right it's a big
deal I think it's Grimace is in 70 but
if you count the first time he was ever
shown he might be seven I think he's
like
because I really feel like you you too I
think I think it's like Yoda where
they're just saying like
he's a thousand but who cares he's he's
80. you know what I mean like Yoda said
yodi's Yoda is a thousand a piece a day
if he's 80 if he's happy if he's yeah if
he's if he's a day all these days or
whatever but uh but so okay does not age
no Grimace has not grown in size so okay
so it'd be like it'd be like Homer
Simpson is 65 today because he's the
show's been on for 65 years like that
kind of thing oh that's my question yes
yes so since the day they showed us him
he was one year old
the characters age they're saying
they're saying the character's been
around for this many years that's what
I'm asking yes but it's a weird well
because I was expecting to see can I
tell you something really yeah like when
did he come out of his mom I I don't
know I always pictured Grimace as being
about
eight or 11 years old somewhere in that
area oh I never really thought of their
ages at all and just now when I'm
talking I told her he was just like uh I
mean he's at like a 30 year old guy he's
not the sharpest tool in the shed Have
you listened to him I mean he's a kid on
Grimace lately I'm not really up on him
and I don't really know does he even
speak yeah he's he's like dude guys like
you know he's like the he's like the uh
the dark history of Grimace oh that's
let me ask you a question we're gonna
lean into this hard evil a lot of
questions originally Grimace was evil oh
I'm wrong he originally was the evil
grimace
oh that's why he was called Grimace
because he was like supposed to be like
a downer who stole milkshakes that's why
there's a Grimace Shake
wow okay when did he turn Face
uh he's got an extended family with an
uncle Emily and Tilly
and then
an orish uncle
what does that word oh I guess it's a
color maybe is that who was that he is
that like Wookie is that what he isn't
it no representing Irish accent okay
he's got an Irish accent no no and an
orange uncle named yeah it says Irish
so there's a Grimace that carries a
knife around there's green wait where do
you see a knife sheleighly
wait right there Shirley carrying green
grimace
his uncle what what's a Chile oh knife a
chalet is a knife yeah they couldn't
have attached a more weird like because
it's an Irish it's a traditional Irish
knife but and his uncle is Irish it's so
not intimidating like be careful he's
got a shillelae I think it's a cool name
for a knife really yeah but it's like
dude take one more step bro take one
more step and this Chile is going right
through your thigh meat so but here's an
interesting point
here's an expression oh this was my next
question I was going to ask do you think
two Grimace has had sex to make another
Grimace or was this she just someone I
was gonna say to speaking to your point
he's got aunts and uncles so there has
to be an age so there okay yes that's
true and you're right and Grimace is a
thing he's a he he is a species yes he
is a species it wasn't like it wasn't
like you know an elephant had sex with
like a grape and right yeah yeah and by
the way speaking of thigh meat did you
see what's going on today
you have made the shorts
but I've seen him in shorts this is
first initial day I revealed them oh on
the on the street oh those but this one
cut off so were those bought as cutoffs
all my cut-offs are genuine cutoffs I
didn't already at first spokes pair of
jeans I don't want any walk and I cut
the I cut them off because then it's
I've said this before then it's not
George to me it's like cool it's like
cut-offs like it's you know not only
issue this yeah do you know the length
and do you measure it or do you eye it
and do you do a technique where you cut
some off and then you cut a little more
off and then you cut a little more off
to make sure you don't over cut one cut
one cut all the time one cut and at this
point
well at this point I have different pair
and I know the lengths of them should I
go I want them to be this long so I just
measure it the pants to that pair from
the inseam yeah no I just I just line
them up it's not an exact same the other
pair yeah okay sometimes I'll put them
on and do do the cut but not really so
you could Mark where they're going to be
yeah they all fall around the same area
no I got something shorter this is a
shorter pair
wow look at that yeah you're you're oh
there you go yeah I like right above the
knee when I was younger man I did stuff
like mid calf
I've got ones that go to here yeah and I
like them but they're good for like
hanging by the pool they're a little too
much in public drapes around Europe in
the summer or something
you got to make a pair on Instagram I
need to see it all right it's not going
to be very interesting can I give you a
little Revenue stream that you hadn't
had praiah sign George
no no
no no that's probably easier what I was
going to say is send Joe your dungarees
you lightly warn you dungarees and he
will make them into Jorts for you
and he will mail them back so they're
Joey roses did Joey Rose's Jord approved
he cut your Jorts I don't think I wanted
this responsibility in any way there's
the green Grimace the uh I'm gonna ruin
somebody's pants
no matter what comes out of it you you
you me you created the jort for them
it's all part of the it's something it's
something it's something to think about
I mean we're all you know send it with a
self-addressed uh post pre-post paid uh
thing and then all you gotta do is get
it slice them send it back and you got
to send a cashier's check just started
George Etsy
yeah maybe no but then you're buying
juice
of all the people I know can I say this
can I say this
of all the people I know I should have
an Etsy
I've got an artsy hand
I'm good with a craft and an art that
was not a sentence I thought you were
gonna say I literally thought you're
gonna say pimp that's a great idea you
know I paint I should be selling my
paintings
let's back it up to the center let's
back up to the original sentence
how many people would you say you know
quite a few some have etsy's already I'm
not counting those people you know 500
people
like technically I'm sure probably but I
just made it my immediate life
well you're the one that does that
should be having an Etsy they have all
the ones that don't have an answer yet I
think I should have an Etsy you think
you should have Etsy more than me
I've never seen you do one artsy crafty
thing in my life yeah but it doesn't
matter I have a passion for it you do
and in fact I do think you should have
an Etsy because you love to get a
t-shirt made and I actually think you
would be great at designing a 50
t-shirts I know that's what I'm saying I
think you'd be great at designing your
own t-shirts there are websites that'll
let you do it and selling your own
shirts on Etsy dude can I tell you about
a shirt I don't mean Sal vulcano merch
you know I mean like designs yeah that's
what I always that's like yeah I would
love to do that yeah uh can I don't want
people to steal my idea though can you
drop it
okay no yes I don't know maybe I'll give
it I want to get a t-shirt made that
says oh you should that's great you
should why would you like it no I want
to I'm just I just didn't want to did
you get the shirt yet
oh I did I did oh wait you got it I did
I forgot who sent it sorry you forgot I
know we had a conversation I know I know
I I was staring at like I know someone
said to me I know I had a conversation
about this but I don't know who said we
were pretty cocked up when I said yeah
yeah I'm sitting next to each other
couch all right we had done many shots
together at that point and I said and I
go I just bought this I know I know I
had this conversation I know someone
said is it any good does it fit I I can
I tell you it was lackluster really the
transfer of the decal onto the shirt
both in texture and in placement
placement is my big thing and then I
looked and I said God damn I can't even
correct this because I don't remember
who gave it to me yeah it was me it was
me and it was the only one I could find
what's his name Bustamante Paul buffano
bubble clothing on a cruise Bustamante
the apology
that's this is like when you got me the
sauce the gravy is getting made sure and
it was too big ah was it yeah and I just
I had to wear it I had to wear like a
chick in the 80s like a night shirt okay
with panties
what shirt was that
because it was it was like I got the
sauce I got into the debate with you
guys we went on vacation and somebody
said I said I'm gonna make gravy for
everybody somebody said it's not a
summer dish and I said the gravy is
getting made
me a shirt that said it which was
awesome but it was too big
um that's a bummer the Paul Buffon damn
it man oh well yeah I'll bring it in
I'll show you you tell me all right wait
let's ship these before it gets to by
the way shout outs to all the fans and I
don't want to single any one person out
because so many people have sent this to
me
two McDonald's things uh one is the um
the uh kicks the custom McDonald's kicks
that are getting made
like for sneaker heads that I've
received from multiple people and then
the second link oh you've gotten
multiple pairs of sneakers no no a link
to where you can buy them oh yeah yeah
like look at this these are out and then
I've gotten even more of
the uh announcement today that
McDonald's in certain countries is
offering like wedding catering packages
for like 230 bucks ahead
I only have one big thing taken off of
the uh to-do list for the wedding yeah
yeah there you go uh a friend of mine
got married on April on April Fool's Day
uh and I was at his wedding it was like
at this point I I literally must be
maybe almost 20 years ago or if so and
he they the waiters brought out ham and
cheese on white bread for dinner to all
the guests oh is it April fools yeah
well that's great yeah I mean I think
people knew right away but they went
they've committed and they followed
through with it and they all put them on
the plate and how long did they make
everybody wait for the food I don't
recall I would have sat there until
somebody actually complained and I would
have said get the out of my wedding
you in great April fools everybody else
gets food now I ripped that card open
and adjusted the number on that check
immediately
I mean who'd be mad at a ham and cheese
I'd be thrilled with him it's my tide
for my favorite sandwich
I actually liked it better than than
what
what let's ship this before it melts and
also the age by the way do you want to
get to the bottom of the oh wait the age
that's what I was gonna say so they're
making such a big Grimace as a child
they're making such a big stink out of
his birthday I'm expecting because I was
about to go in on him hard right now now
I feel bad because he's youth take age
guesses you've heard the clamoring
around this birthday yeah I I'm I'm
don't pull up the screen I'll tell you
but I want you to take a few guesses can
I just say how confused I am because you
just mentioned he had aunts and uncles
so it has to be an age but we're going
by the day that McDonald's introduced
him right so he's gonna be like well
let's call it the anniversary let's call
it the Grimace anniversary they've made
a big stink out of this throw some
numbers out I'm gonna say
that Grimace is
61.
61. yeah I think I placed him being
being born in 1962. okay is that 61.
yeah okay
you want it
50.
60.
in a crazy world 75. okay
it's 52. it's such a weird why 50 why
why the stink at 52. oh like yep is it
just because they need something to to
promote because the Grimace shake they
need to promote I just would think they
would say guys at fifth when Grimace
turns 55 we're rolling this out
how about 50. well maybe they missed the
boat at 50 and didn't think of it but 52
is a very odd but but one of my biggest
birds the whole reasons was 27 for no
reason right it's just very weird for a
corporate chain to go 52 Grimace maybe
there's something we don't know about
like like Heinz you know what like well
yeah you know what I could think it
could be
um Grimace erotica exists
yeah I'd like to read the next step of
the Grimace Veronica please do you know
what I think it could be there's an
Barney movie coming out and maybe
they're trying to cash in on that how
would they cash in from the Barney movie
coming out maybe Brands confusion when
you said today let's put Grimace against
Barney yeah
because they're big purple dinosaur
monsters whatever like
maybe they just thought Now's the Time
to celebrate Grimace the our polls tell
our poll testing tells us okay the
people like a purple monster right now
and you're sure that this guy speaks or
is it a guy we found out what it was do
you remember we found out it was I think
on episode one
pimp didn't you well he's a he's a taste
bud oh yes yes oh wait I forgot about it
he's a literal taste bud personified yes
anthromorphosized anthromorphic yeah
anthropomorphic
[Music]
Joe hey buddy do you find that in the
summer it might be hard to stay on top
of your Wellness uh I do I find that
it's often just tough for me I'm a guy
that's a little Restless I'm a guy
that's a little anxious as you are what
about our sleep schedules going on the
road uh that changes all the time for me
and I gotta be honest when I'm home my
sleep schedule ain't no walk in the park
either I just have a hard time you can
stay on track with CB d right next Evo
Naturals developed smart sorb technology
clinically proven to help your body
absorb the CBD four times better than
regular CBD oil because oil just doesn't
mix with your water-based body it works
faster too when you need to de-stress
and sleep better this summer reach for
next Evo problem uh I like the product
uh as I said we're two guys that are
anxious it helps us alleviate the
anxiety the stress it helps with
sleeping better that's a big one for me
I have a lot of hard sleep habits uh and
I have a lot of sleep issues I like this
product for that reason it is helping me
alleviate these issues so I can enjoy
things like I don't know sleep mandatory
sleep absolutely you know yeah and next
Evo test their product multiple times to
ensure you get 100 of what is on that
label uh next Evo Naturals CBD Sleek
sleep complex combines CBD with
melatonin so you can wake up refreshed
and keep your sleep schedule stay well
this summer with smarter CBD from next
Evo Naturals go to nextevo.com tastebuds
to get 20 off your first order of 40 or
more that's 20 off at next Evo next
evo.com slash taste buds
so I like cashews do
Bears yes yes yes
what about sesame sticks dried fruit
there's not a thing you said that I
don't like chocolate covered espresso
beans bam boom bap well you're gonna go
to nuts.com I love nuts.com okay they've
been around forever and I love their
packaging and I know that sounds funny
but I'm a stickler I love a good package
I love a good package nuts.com has the
kind of packaging where if I saw it out
in the wild as I was shopping for other
things I would grab it and throw it into
it I do agree yeah no I said and let me
tell you something I have the whole
Suite of products in my house yeah yeah
and let me tell you the chocolate
covered gummy bears yeah I know tdf I
know their problems yeah nuts.com is
your One Stop Shop of freshly roasted
nuts dried fruit sweets Pantry Staples
like specialty flowers and more of their
wide selection means there's something
for everyone uh they're offering plenty
of gluten-free options as well organic
choices other diet friendly products
whether you're looking for something
sweet Savory or whatever maybe you just
need to stock up on everyday cooking
Essentials you're gonna find some
something that you want to try at
nuts.com and I'll add one more thing
they roast their nuts and pop their corn
the same day it ships so it's always
deliciously fresh right now nuts.com is
offering new customers a free gift with
purchase and free shipping on orders of
29 or more at nuts.com taste buds so go
check out all the delicious options they
have at nuts.com tastebuds you'll
receive a free gift and free shipping
when you spend 29 or more that's
nuts.com taste buds here we go ready
folks Joe DeRosa here I am hitting the
road doing the live thing September 16th
I'll be in Avenel New Jersey at the
Avenal Performing Arts Center September
21st through 23rd coming back to Toronto
Canada for the Just for Laughs Festival
2023 uh going to be in Las Vegas for
skank Fest in September uh the 29th
through October 1st and then
Philadelphia Pennsylvania My Hometown
Theater of the Living Arts November 11th
I've got a ton of new dates coming soon
visit jodarosa.com for all information
on shows venues ticket links etc etc and
folks I've been teasing it for a while
the big announcement is here salsa
windfall the single is out now mouth on
my money available on All Digital
platforms and the new album artificial
birth comes out August birth
fourth
birth fourth we're back baby uh salsa
windfall out now single mouth of my
money go get it and then the album comes
in August come check it out uh and then
we've got more salsa windfall news
coming very very soon it's exciting very
exciting I'm excited about it and last
but not least if you're in the city come
to Joey roses for God's sakes
joeyrosesnyc.com come get a beer
sandwich a whiskey whatever the hell you
want it's always a good time
all right kids the Impractical Jokers
and Eric Andre are throwing a cruise
January 22nd to the 26th and 24. it's
three quarters sold out but it's going
to be a blast Comics bands DJs All That
Jazz tickets right now at get
shipfacedcruise.com I got the last
weekend of the first leg of the tour
with the guys coming up July 27th
through the 29th you can get tickets at
impracticaljokerslive.com we're doing
Nashville at the Grand Ole Opry game
Bridge Field House in Indianapolis and
at the stifle theater for two in St
Louis and then my big announcement I am
filming my special a December in Chicago
and I got the tour leading up to that
we're gonna be hitting Albany Hartford
and Syracuse funny bones and then going
to Bowling Green Cincinnati Toledo
Wilkes bar Wilmington Macon Georgia
Savannah and Athens Georgia Peoria
Rockford Illinois Cedar Rapids
Springfield Illinois uh just a ton of
that's at salvolcanocomedy.com
appreciate you see you on the road so
can we just get a clip of him talking
pimp I don't think he'll talk in this
because they're they're because of uh
licensing I mean he stopped stealing
shakes a long time ago but he still has
the uh the crazy hips yes big hips
there's got to be a a a
ah there here he goes
yeah if I remember correctly he's like
hey guys like that all right Grimace
where you going just gonna suck up a
little song yes you're soaking up a
little Sun we'll soak up some McDonald's
Frosty thick shakes
my impression was pretty dead
it sounds like anything that you would
think
so look he's either a kid or a slow
adult one or the other right that Ronald
actor
also deliver that line like a very very
normal human being like he should have
been a little more Clowny he's like well
if you're gonna do that we're gonna do
this
now he puts up
[Music]
quick this is this is lunacy this looks
like a fever dream
this is insane
strawberry vanilla shake well I
certainly hope you learned something
from this Grimace oh I certainly have
that actor is uh that's I know who that
actor is
that's the guy from um he had a lisp and
and that that actor's the guy from uh
he's like he was like a character actor
on sitcoms and stuff I wish I could
remember his name right now I know who
that was though can I just say um is it
me or does he basically sound like
Barney
yeah so Barney jacked
Barney stole Jesus wait a minute did we
just uncover that Barney just stole
grimace
could pull up a barn Barney talking
how old is Barney
1988. I don't think Barney sounds like
as dumb though I love you
right but I think like
[Music]
nah that's not Barney oh
feels like more Flintstones kind of ask
can we go but that's not Barney talking
though that's uh that's that bird
no
where's Bonnie at
call it was special for me too
it's similar but no Barney Grimace State
like in that McDonald's commercial that
Grimace was like dumb
like hit with something yeah that's what
I'm saying yeah all right let's try the
shake before we get to the battle I
think it should be DeRosa first here all
right
this is gonna set off my milk allergy
too
can you reserve how you feel so I don't
know if you like it I don't like it yep
Ready
[Music]
okay wow really good poker face thank
you I thought you were gonna forget and
not say how you feel but I thought you
were gonna like at least I would read it
on your face thank you really excellent
all right thank you very much I'm gonna
pull up as I go so I get uh I top it off
with a little whipped cream from the top
there I'm gonna chase it with some fries
by the way
my whipped cream
argument in full effect right here look
how disgusting that is already
delicious to me
all right
do you want to give your take first or
do you want me to give my take first
I don't like it at all wow
I don't like it it's it's it's so
it's so sweet it is really sweet
it's so sweet one gobble that's like
whoa but if I drank that whole thing
right now I would probably be bouncing
off the walls and have a headache and
yeah like I I mean like it's not a
bad flavor it's not offensive but it's
like it tastes like what does it taste
like it tastes like crunch berries kind
of yeah
it tastes like if you took the milk from
French berries rape yeah there is a
weird tartness in there
hmm
it's super sweet you know what it tastes
like holy crap
it tastes like something see my drink
over there I need a side of you
you know what it tastes like
yeah
dude this is dead on okay hold on hold
on
it's something it's gonna blow your mind
I'm tasting a familiarity it's gonna
blow your mind it's not crunch Berry
it's a flavor from years ago
it's annoying I got it okay
it tastes like grape nerd cereal
that's there is grape coming yeah you're
right you're right it's nerd cereal
because nerd cereal was like but it
tastes like grape nerd a little bit
that's what nerd cereal tasted like like
it was like Fruity like tartness but
then like a creaminess and then the milk
Fruity Pebbles taste in there
a little bit
but that's that's
but there's something about I I get it I
get it if I was a kid I'd be like Jesus
yeah
there's something about drinking a
flavor like that versus eating it and
for some reason like eating that like
let's just call it crunch berries eating
crunch berries
delicious it's fun whatever there's
something that happens when you turn it
into drinking it where I'm like it's too
much it's too much for me I can't do it
yep
now in honor of Grimace and also I feel
like this is really a celebration of Joe
I think Sal should try his first Big Mac
on air
oh
I just had a healthy meal but one but I
don't understand what one bite's gonna
do well I already sipped a Grimace I'm
already double shifting 15 grams of
sugar at least I I might have to bite
one of these Big Macs you must he might
have to I'm trying to it's like it's
like you forget about it well it's these
have been sitting here too this is not
going to be wow and sell an honest
review
what's the big thing here what's the big
selling point
just the way it all comes together like
the spongy Triple Decker
the Special Sauce
the you know the the it's just all the
elements the shredded lettuce the minced
onion like it all just kind of comes
together now when it's warm it's great
this is a little you know I don't think
this is going to be the best version
ever if I were you though when did they
start rocking a seated bun see that
backside Big Macs have Big Macs and
Quarter Pounders always have seated buns
see that backside
yeah that creamy side no no no no that
that part that's where you want to go
that's what I don't want really yeah I
don't love um a special sauce
tell me what's in it and like let me
just you know it's Russian dressing it's
you know I don't really love Russian
dressing all right
uh I love you guys and I'm going to pass
um just because I don't want the taste
in my mouth or body
because then later I'll be I'll be
tasting Big Mac later and stuff and
it's really good
I also don't want to be tempted to have
a second bite which I might which I
might
yeah
oh wow let's let's guys everyone pause
your radios and your YouTubes for a
moment while Joe has a moment we will be
right back
you're right now I gotta I want to eat
the whole thing now that's what I'm
saying wash it down with some shake bro
you're gonna wash it down with some
shake the cold front you're eating fries
you're now now you are eating McDonald's
and we are just waiting you eat
McDonald's breakfast one
he had his own animated TV show here in
99. what was it
Adventures of Grimace how did he on a
channel on a network or The Adventures
of Ronald
right okay it says the Wacky Adventures
of Ronald McDonald
what what wacky adventure you think
Ronald would go on what's an example of
a wacky adventure there I don't know
explain to the cops why you got six kids
in your car
that's yeah in this week's episode uh
Ronald spends the weekend in the jail
because he got arrested on a Friday
night
um so we should oh good I was gonna kind
of lean into this right now good good
please lean all right they're both two
big purple monstrosities uh I'll be the
first to say that Barney I I was I
wasn't young enough to to have Barney in
my life as the kid he wasn't my
demographic and I also am someone who
thought that like the song I didn't want
to hear it it's like
baby shark almost like I just don't want
to hear the damn song okay so
like in general that would have swayed
my opinion but when I had to think about
him in this light and think about the
positives of Barney and why he's better
than Grimace things come to mind and
that's why I was able to accept the
challenge okay
uh
I think
you're not and I have stuff to back this
up now I think you're all right let's
just start the battle Yeah do we need
the
let's just in honor his 52nd birthday
let's just get right into it let's just
loving battle all right that's fine okay
ready yeah time two
b-a-t-t-l-e buds see the chance you're a
little under understeemed today that's
what I was thinking we needed to but
it's fine don't worry all right I think
you're nuts
taking on Barney in this fight uh
because
I I mean I can't think of them I can't
think of a children's character who over
time has been more hated than Barney
like like I mean listen you you know
haters are gonna hate and when you're at
the top looking down everyone's gonna
try to take a swipe at you every other
purple monster is gonna try to take a
swipe at you Grimace you can't even say
he's hated because
he's not he doesn't really matter and it
doesn't matter
at 52. where were they when Grimace was
one to 51 rather if you use a side piece
if you say he's an ancillary character
he's a supporting role if you say it's
not even a supporting role he's in an
ensemble cast but but but but he's in
but he's in that ensemble cast is
Seinfeld dude
do you understand you it's better to be
George Costanza on Seinfeld then Barney
is still Third Rock From the Sun
but here's my point
I'd rather be he is
but you'd rather be George Costanza on
Seinfeld than John Lithgow on Third Rock
You just what
you just would yeah but you're you're
interested
are true yeah I'd rather be Costanza I
would rather pick a stands on Seinfeld
than John Lithgow in third Arc with his
son but that is
how insulting this is to Jason Alexander
that we just keep calling him George
Costanza but we're calling John lithgows
his real name I didn't even notice but
it's speed it supports my point because
nobody remembers character's name
it's it's Ronald McDonald then Grimace
he's the he's the second guy that
everybody remembers hamburglars up there
somewhere mayor machines is in there
somewhere but my point is I'll give you
the most iconic
yes the most iconic restaurant mascots
ever Grimace is in is number two he's
your point he's your point guard not
point guard what's the second you get
your guardian point guard right power
forward I don't know well well Ronald's
your point guard right yeah he's Pippin
whatever the hell yeah whatever forward
so
but Barney but Bonnie okay first of all
Barney has
a liberal loving demon
I will say this Barney at least has a
full-on identity Barney is big in size
because he's a dinosaur
we know where he comes from we know what
he's about Grimace we had to look up to
figure out that he was a taste bud and
no one knows that and he doesn't have
any traits that would
make us believe he's a taste bud he
doesn't he doesn't encapsulate what his
character is dude whereas Barney you
know you're reading while I'm talking no
I'm listening and listening to what
you're saying I'm listening to what
you're saying I would retort I would I
would report to one of the things you
just said you didn't need to know what
Grimace was sure that was the power oh
you don't but look he's no somebody's
got to talk to him about his size
somebody has to talk to me about his
weight
since he was born he's he's lifting
shakes and he's got the thighs and the
and the bottom he's got a bob he's
pear-shaped he might as well be a purple
pear right
Barney is not Barney is healthy for all
intents and purposes he's a dinosaur and
he's bit that's why he's big and he
probably has a very like a paleo diet
actually Barney uh Barney Barney says
just shoveling into his mouth he
hangs out with miscreants he hangs out
with a burglar he hangs out here he
hangs out with these Fry Guys nobody
knows what part of town those guys come
from nobody knows what they're up to
After Hours the fry guys but in real
you'd be better off sticking to the
attributes of Barney right now because
I'm telling you you're gonna get creamed
Barney Barney is so it's so I get it
he's popular and he and people are gonna
hate on popular stuff but Barney it it
was like a trend it was like a cultural
phenomenon how much people hated Barney
like I have never seen anything like
that but his demographic I love you you
love me that's like scenario to those
kids
I'm telling all right all right their
scenario he's that's a great point and
he is cemented in songs look he's part
of the Lexicon yes uh but look at this
look at grimace's too but look at this
dude uh tell you what I do in the summer
I go to a lot of Live Events I go to
sports I go to concerts
you name it and you never know if you're
getting the best deal on tickets and a
lot of times I want to go I don't want
to plan two months and a half yeah you
want to go last week so game time who
now uh sponsors this podcast what they
do they make buying last minute tickets
super simple to your favorite events no
stress it's fast and easy way for sports
music comedy theater killer deals on
last minute tickets the best price
guarantee if you find a price cheaper uh
they will give you 110 of your money
forget planning months in advance game
time is deals on tickets up to the day
of the event exclusive Flash Deals on
tickets for football basketball baseball
concerts comedy and theater the game
time guarantee means you'll always get
the best price I agree uh game time is
great they're making it quick they're
making it easy they're making you focus
on getting to that event and enjoying it
just going to that event instead of
freaking out and stressing out about
getting the tickets to the event uh it's
it's just so convenient it's so cheap
it's it's well it's it's so convenient
it's the cheapest available thing why
it's the fastest growing ticket app in
the country yeah and then again they
have this guarantee if you find tickets
in your rower section that are cheaper
than the ones you paid for on game time
game time is going to credit you 110 of
that difference yeah uh okay download
the game time app create an account use
promo code taste buds you're going to
get 20 off your first purchase this is
how you snag the tickets without the
stress with game time terms to apply
again create an account and redeem code
taste buds for twenty dollars off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed
there are there's a trend of YouTube
videos of Barney toys getting destroyed
he's been parried on an SNL
um there's a song called Barney's on
fire by Maze Tony Mason this is insane
there's a Jihad to destroy him an online
group in the early 90s that was
dedicated to defamation humiliation
eradication killing and removal of
Barney the purple dinosaur of the
television show Barney and Friends from
the Airways and from every human's life
Barney is a liberal loving demon
the story here is about North Carolina
Pastor Reverend Joseph Chambers who
really doesn't trust the TV character
his booklet the purple Messiah was
published in 93 and talks about an
episode where mother gooth comes out of
the nursery rhymes after Barney chance
shimbura shimbura the magic words from
the early days I think I claimed it was
witchcraft
he calls the show Barney and Friends the
antithesis of the Bible he also has
critical of the fact that there's too
much diversity and he accused this is
the headline though he accuses Barney of
trying to beat Jesus yes and the PA and
the priest also says or Pastor whatever
he is I forget already Reverend yeah uh
I'm not teach I'm not for teaching
people that pedophiles and homosexuals
are on the same level as parents who's a
pedophile homosexual well that's the
thing that certain people like to do
where they if they don't like something
they say that everybody's a pedophile on
par part of it I mean it's a children's
character I mean that's this guy where's
he right now did you just did you just
touch my fry until it wasn't pointing it
yeah I mean that's it's you're not gonna
eat that far you got a whole bucket
right there all right but there was a
crazy I only did that for that reason
all right the CIA uses the theme song to
torture prisoners well I know this and
this is what I was going to say is
actually a plus for Barney you're not
gonna flip this on me Barney's doing
literally the federal work okay he's a
member of the CIA and that's true we
talk about that on stage in the new tour
in practical jokers toys right yeah yes
I do I remember I saw it it's called
Sonic acoustic correction and it's they
blast that until people give up but do
you understand information he is doing
government work but he's like the guy
the government says doesn't exist
because he has to do such Rhymes
they're like we don't have any record of
we don't have any record of a Barney
here he's exactly no he is Rambo they
don't
wait you're not going to compare Barney
to ramble right now and make that as a
negative Rambo doesn't exist on
government papers do you understand
that's right I'm just saying it's a
boogeyman there's a Darkness
there's your darkness when you need him
there's a Darkness there he he
basically
scene where they come back and they go
look Barney like the guy comes and sits
down with him that's still in full
uniform and Beret in his in his living
room and he goes he knocks on the door
and Barney closes goes to close the door
immediately and he goes wait please just
let me in give me just give me two
minutes just give me two minutes he goes
I told you I'm not about that life
anymore he says just give me two minutes
he goes fine
maybe the wife makes a cup of tea or
something they sit down yeah
I've given enough to this word we need
you yeah we need we need your image and
like this and voice we need you because
you are the only thing they're going to
drive these people out of this compound
they're holed up in and uh we need to
get them out and Barney's like I don't I
don't I don't want to do it but he does
it every time he does it every time and
I think he does want to do it I think
that's how he gets off and I think he's
sick
it's two different levels
and that's the beauty of Grimace dude
he's under the radar he's not polarizing
his name he's over here
Grimace is not good he's the the man has
a man named Grimace and he's loved can
you Grimace with me right now can you
Grimace what's your best Grimace I gotta
be honest I've always had a bit of a a
confusion about a Grimace being is it as
frown or is it a uh like a scowl
it all will be revealed a Grimace is an
ugly Twisted expression that's exactly
what I was asking typically expressing
disgust pain or rye Amusement a scowl a
frown a sneer a pout a wince so he's a
that's the personification
of a Grimace but it's but he's the
opposite of that so he's got enough he's
got it's like when you call a short guy
a tall guy tiny
you know what I mean like it's like he's
got an opposite nickname you see what
I'm saying so you're saying he's not
doing that he doesn't he doesn't Grimace
but but but but but why then why call
him that he's good appealing too no they
said originally boots are evil
he was going to be a thief yeah no he
was a thief until he turned well so talk
about his past is he expunged he stole
Limitless stuff from children Limitless
the what now it's story of redemption
yeah yeah no stop it pimp he's a
Defector no this is we're not this isn't
even this isn't even a questionable
tweet this man was evil he stole it's on
record he's a Defector he's a Defector
where's his where his where's his
comeuppance these are the fact they
promoted him up yeah he's a Defector if
a guy goes I just left the Death Star I
was working over there I was pretty high
up the ladder uh I'm here now to work
for the Rebellion you put that guy in a
high seat all right so you're telling me
this guy is is basically from the empire
I'm saying he's a Defector and he did
and he used his powers for good and now
here he is Barney's on Front Street
Barney didn't have to make a face turn
Barney's the happy-go-lucky guy that
Grimace wants to be but Barney is right
on on Front Street with that from the
get there's something very he's just
walking around he don't want no problems
he doesn't want to say this oh he's
about it
he's about I will say this and I and I
really do mean this
and it's just follow me on this but
trust me
there's something phony about Barney
there's something like sterile about it
there's something milk toast hold on
there's something hold on but there's
something but I'm not from his error but
it but when I saw that the kid right now
identifies with a second when I was a
teenager and I saw Barney
the first thing ever I think that's why
everybody hates him they go God when I
was a kid like Children's Entertainment
had so much more weight to it like it
just had more texture Barney has always
from the jump it's been so sanitized and
sterilized and phony and fake and thin
and it's just it's just boring there's
just nothing it's not going to appeal to
you well but it's not going to appeal to
me but I could I you you could you could
name things that did appeal to kids of
that same age demographic look at h r
Puffin stuff it's so much cooler it's
for the same age group it's so much
cooler there's so much more texture to
it there's so much more weight to it
there it's aesthetically every aspect of
it is better Barney aesthetically is
boring it looks it looks airbrushed it
looks a purple blob with two eyes
Brothers he's aesthetically boring you
tell me you're telling me but he's not
he has nothing you're telling me you see
that you see that big purple bastard you
don't light up you tell me that you do
and you know you can't see one purple
bastard and light up in the other person
I can I feel like put them next to each
other pimp put put side by side Barney
and grimace
dude I would want Barney by my side
instead of Grimace in almost any
situation dude look at was about to
go down I want Barney look Barney is a
dinosaur and he has Mobility Grimace is
literally he can't do nothing but waddle
I'm saying though I'm saying let's let's
talk in very literal terms here let's
let's let's talk very literally about
this and not in a figurative like one's
a Tinus or Wednesday let's just talk
literally
look at the difference look at the
different look at Barney's dead eyes
like it looks creepy yeah but look at
grimace's literal he has the weight of
the world in those eyes but I'm Chase
he's the best with children but that's
my point of these people one is phony
one of these people teaches children
the other one literally helps give
children diabetes right
the diabetes one is grimace
how does grimace help give children
diabetes he steals their milkshakes
he steals the shame I'm holding he's
saving children specialty birthday shake
that you just said they're going ape
with with funding to make this the
biggest thing ever guess who this is
targeted toward the most I could argue
that Barney ruins kids brains by dumbing
them down with stupid songs and
oversimplified messages
I don't I think it's a very good I mean
have you heard a children's song
it's like some of them are Bach and he's
like he's coming in like stain that's
that's not true that's not true at all
that's not true at all the uh I've heard
many a children's song and many of them
look you don't get you're you're you're
your signature song does not become the
leading form of Sonic torture by the
caiia for no reason my my but anything
but but do you see my point there are a
million children songs that people go no
that's too lack of a song anything
that's not in moderation is going to do
that to you you play any song 100 times
you know what I mean you know what I
mean no I honestly when I'm thinking
about it there's a reason Wheels on the
Bus and still in my children some
Hallmarks of what it what it means to be
a human being right I I if you think
about he really wraps it up nicely it's
all about love and family you know we
only have so much time on this rock you
know I love you you love me we're a
happy there's a reason there is
there is a reason there is a reason like
there are certain songs that I love you
as one of them Wheels on the Bus Go
Round And rounds one of them there is a
reason why when parents when people talk
about Annoying children songs they go to
the same four or five songs every time
and don't and don't name a million
others it's because they are grading
horrifically epitomizingally annoying
songs because they were so popular that
they become so ubiquitous that you can't
help but over listen to them and so it
happens naturally and inherently because
the song was such a Smash Hit I think
it's saccharin I think it's the same way
like if you let a kid saccharin is with
you miss pushes but no no but hold on
but if you let a kid literally if you
let it if you said to a kid eat whatever
you want for dinner the kid would eat
Twizzlers or Sour Patch Kids or or ice
cream whatever he would over sugar
himself to death and I think when you
say to a kid what song do you want to
hear because it's a kid it's not
literally going to hurt him in an
immediate sense they go they go for the
same most saccharine shitty thing and
that's that's our that's that's why it
got overplayed it didn't get overplayed
because it was great it's because kids
are dumb and they don't understand
what's good and they listen to the worst
thing for them so your argument right
now is going to put all children yep
you're going to group them together and
say children are dumb and they don't
know why would they be any better than
the than the average group of any
there's that George Carlin joke children
are like any other group of people a few
winners whole lot of losers it's true
it's very true they're just averages
anybody else but they're children listen
to what the more an adults listen to so
what does grimace give to the children
what does he give he's a great character
Barney's out here trying he he warms
your heart without even knowing if he
can speak warms your heart yes it looks
like a he looks like a discarded heart
you're not but you're you're not making
a point
he shows up up he clocks and he stands
next to Ronald nobody knows what he is
or what he does but he's beloved shall
it's just there's no argument I don't
know I don't know to be honest because
McDonald's can't be flexed with and
Grimace is just a Brilliant Invention on
their part like everything else and they
just know how to strike a chord I
honestly can't tell you why
editorializing by saying that grimace's
beloved and Barney is is is is literally
the entire Globe is celebrating his
birthday right now he's below this is
what is wrong with you McDonald's is in
the recesses of your brain right now
because at McDonald's is selling the
shake and putting up ads for it and
saying let's go get it doesn't mean the
whole world is celebrating some figures
on how well the Grimace Shake sold to
Joe's Credit I do want to say he is
fighting world hunger Grimace is on the
front lines that is true he's making
affordable Food for People he's fighting
he's fighting world hunger with obesity
it's just as bad you want everyone
hungry you want everyone gonna die from
from having being stuffed with saccharin
as you put it uh it seems to have worked
McDonald's in bed it seems to have
worked
[Laughter]
Grimace has a history of villainy you
saw that he scrolled right past I know
we've but we've we've covered it I want
to know what else we've covered it you
know you know about you know what you
think that's the only time he did the
only thing he did wrong
you think that's the only thing he did
wrong while he was evil what's right
there 700
750 million views on Tick Tock what are
we looking at the the viral the viral
video is McDonald's released for the
Grimace Shake
no no that's not what that said
no yeah you might not get dollar figures
but I mean 750 million views ain't no
dude they just made a video game by the
way you just you just sipped this said
it wasn't good and it was way way too
yeah I didn't like it but 750 million
children are going to be guzzling these
things
what does grimace do I as I said Grimace
kids will literally drink the sweetest
most saccharine thing is like a drug
he's like he might as well be a guy in a
van with candy
that pulls up to a kid and lures them in
we got that's what he is he's giving you
know what he's doing he's basically
who's that guy from The Wire that's out
on the street giving everybody a little
taste a little taste we got that's what
he's doing he's a legalized drug dealer
Grimace he's out there giving all the
kids a little taste he just wants to get
him hooked oh the first one's free Guru
says
yeah and then before you know it the
kids are scratching itching and and and
and and and looking forward they're
looking for the shakes the uh they got
the shakes they become the shakes
pimp cut this all right photo of Grimace
at the fall Berlin hope that influences
your votes that looks photo photoshopped
but still sure it is
here British makes me think of a
tote-sized meal of joy and happiness
Barney reminds me of endless loop of
hypnotic songs I would like to dig out
of my head with a sharp pair of golden
arches very poetic I feel so bad for
grimace he's just trying to celebrate
his birthday
well gee I wonder how they're okay uh I
have to go with Grimace Barney would
listen to wait wait Barney would listen
scroll up Barney would listen to Chrissy
can't
I cannot believe
I cannot believe some people are
willingly choosing Grimace all right
Grimace easily I don't trust anything
that sings about their love for me well
that's something that Brian has to deal
with early sign of my autism is watching
the Barney Christmas videos
[Laughter]
during his birthday celebration Grimace
and Sal should dress up like him for the
next taste buds live not a bad idea for
a punishment if Sal loses this season
I'm picking Grimace because he's got
hilarious Tick Tock what is a hilarious
trend
they're telling you they're tick-tocking
all over the place she's shaking that's
even worse the fact that McDonald's went
through these Tick-Tock idiots
what are you gonna do and it's just it's
all just people with like tons of makeup
on doing a dance and then sipping a
Grimace Shake
uh
uh you feel like Grimace could be Barney
a fight that is so wrong Barney what's
so wrong you know Barney would kick
hermit's ass in the fight right yeah
I'll give you that Barney brought Joy
Grimace brought obesity one sip of
grimace's shake and I'm gonna end up in
Joe's ditch dead
uh the Google images of Grimace are
actually terrifying oh my God
Grimace is an actual family
all right Barney got to me got me to the
point of life where I'm voting for one
purple blob or the other and I'm content
with that
grab a baseball bat and a two by four no
more purple dinosaur
take them out supposedly Grimace is an
enormous taste bud he needs to be made
official unofficial mask out of the pod
has learned Grimace is a taste bud okay
Barney gave us Selena Gomez Grimace gave
us nightmares wow
that by the way that's a great argument
that you missed is his show launched
some child I didn't even know that I
didn't know that either if I was a child
I'd go Barney but Grimace has sunk his
hooks into me as as an adult
Barney although I kind of hate him the
Barney bags recent bias is going to put
Grimace over the top I agree Garrett I
think that you know what are we gonna do
here with celebrating this 750 million
tweets about this this guy on his 52nd
birthday we stand no chance all right
let's go we might as well go back to
Let's this is an ice age that's Humble
Pie it our guest for the next episode is
here so let's Humble Pie and wrap this
up so we can let him in pimpy drum roll
please and we know it's going to be
Grimace come on well I don't know no
because kids are not voting adults are
adults don't like Barney wow that was
way too
very close oh I could have that means
Barney is really the winner here
what are you talking about kids aren't
voting oh Jesus come on
kids aren't voting that's it when's that
ever been a bad thing uh Grimace takes
this one but it's again man we've been
having some clothes 51.7 to 48.3 oh it
just went down wow 51.6 to 48.4 his
comeback man do you see that yeah it's
trending the other way Grimace wins by
the hair of his purple nutsack
holy God well that was way closer than I
thought that was a good battle that
means it was it was good I still love
you I love you too taste buds they
coming to the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like two Fool's gonna fight but only one
food can be right taste buds man yeah
they're coming to them